nominees for Original dramatic score are
John Williams for Amistad Danny Elfman
for Good Will Hunting Philip Glass for
dundun Jerry Goldsmith for LA
Confidential and James Horner for
Titanic and the Oscar goes to James
Horner Titanic
mrs. James boners first Academy Award
who's been nominated seven times for his
work on such films as Braveheart of
Apollo 13
My dear God I'm sort of speechless one
wants this to happen of course but I've
been so close quite a few times but
never actually one I've got to get my
wits about me I don't write speeches
because I'm always so superstitious I
want to thank my wife my family for all
of their support and nourishment Jim
thank you so much for the chance to do
it and musicians who I know so well and
so many other people but I have so
little time I want to thank Michael Gore
faint Jim Henriksen but Michael
girlfriend especially you've been around
so long and I cannot thank you enough
thanks everybody
before we announce this year's Oscar
recipient let's review the nominations
from Hercules go the distance music by
Alan Menken and lyrics by David zipper
from Conair how do I live music and
lyrics by Diane Warren from anastasiya
journey to the past
music by Stephen Flaherty and lyrics by
Lynn Ahrens from Good Will Hunting Miss
Missouri music and lyrics by Elliott
Smith and from Titanic my heart will go
on
music by James Horner and lyrics by Will
Jennings and the Oscar goes to haha what
a shocker and the Oscar goes to James
Horner and will Jennings from my heart
will go on Titanic
this is the second Academy Award for
James Horner and Luke Jenny
well um I want to thank first of all
Rene and Celine for a marvelous
brilliant job thank you so much I cannot
thank you enough Jim Cameron thank you
for being in a good mood that day when I
brought you the song Peter Gelb Glenn
Braun mansoni 550 thank you and Glenn
Beck thank you James for his music and
love to my wife Carole and to all the
people all over the world that took my
heart will go on to their hearts very
thank you